Oh No hello welcome to GameSpot I'm
Peter Brown here with Robert Hanley
how are you we were good friends here to
play a video game we've had a lot of fun
with for the past day or so
yeah I'd say lots of ups and downs sure
sure
this Kingdom Come deliverance new game
for our studios a lot of people know it
in the PC scene but it's also available
on consoles yeah I played it on ps4 last
night I'll be able to talk a little bit
about that
meanwhile let's cut to the intro oh
what's going on oh we're in it welcome
to 2018 No
14:03 there you go yeah so yeah this is
on PC I'm running it um a solid I guess
you could say sixty with high settings
or yeah I have the frame rate on the top
left I want you know I'm I for one like
frame rate so let's keep that consistent
because despite this rig we have here
being pretty awesome
it's got a 10-7 ET TI this game is uh
Peter the schemes a little buggy and I
wouldn't say very well optimized yet and
I believe they've reached out saying
that there will be updates but yes I
mean we'll see we'll see how that works
out you know a game like Skyrim also had
a lot of problems at launch and a lot of
those problems exists today
how many ports later how many years
later we'll see what happens we and what
we can't say is this is a very ambitious
game it's big there's a lot of stuff
that it's trying to juggle all at once
and it drops a few balls here and there
yeah I'm over this in travel so I I'll
just sort of summarize the deal you are
Henry the son of a blacksmith for the
king and you got wasted and got in a
fight the night before the game started
there's papa and or husband women are
not they don't get a lot of screen time
they get a lot they get a lot of
fondling czar fondled a lot a lot of
zoom ins on their butts yeah whatever
very just blame it's a man's world I
guess basically you're Henry you gotta
run some errands to get on your dad's
good side and then [ __ ] goes south we're
gonna try to run through the sections
somewhat quickly mm-hmm because I think
we know what to do and if we're lucky
there was a glitch that happened to me
twice yesterday on both platforms I
played it on but with different timing
where the gentleman who has the things
that who Oh is your dad some stuff if
you take him out quickly and then go do
another thing to initiate a cutscene he
will pop up in the middle of that
cutscene and tell you to take everything
even though you've already robbed him
and he's just wearing his shirt so yeah
anyway
Trump nation in chat says game is boring
it could be boring that's the thing is I
think this is a little devices because
this is a $60 game right like yep
either you embrace the bugginess or
don't buy this game and the bucking this
can be charming and it sounds like funny
like we're we were laughing a lot you've
already seen some gifts and memes
already on on the web yeah it's like on
the one hand yes it does sort of hurt
you know the you being embedded in the
narrative and taking every moment and
just event seriously but you can look
past that if you really want to but
there are problems with the game that
can cause you to not be able to progress
such as not being able to sit and the
save your game because yes this game
requires you to either find a bed to
sleep to save or expand an item that
costs a lot of gold there is no quick
save as it were unless you hack the game
a design decision that people very
quickly or if you have saviours schnapps
save your schnapps right that being a
very expensive thing it's like an item
and you're given early on three save
your snot right which allow you to do a
manual save three times and but the
scary thing though
the scary thing though is that if you go
into the menu and you see save
highlighted and you just hit it the game
doesn't like wait are you sure you want
to use that item it's just like cool
thanks done yeah item item gone yeah
that's right it did that's exactly what
happens in a way I know I like the so
this the save is I would say it goes
hand-in-hand with like your your choice
making right like because of your auto
saves being so few and far between then
when you make a couple of times I've had
situations that like occurred right and
the gravity is then far more severe and
that was kind of neat we're like I had a
bunch of lockpicks and I was unable to
open a chest meaning that it is
something else we'll get to it therefore
I had to then rely on like my bully
friends to beat up that yeah that one
guy who owes you money so like you're
kind of like forced into into situations
that maybe you're not
so there were your intention and that's
that's kind of neat I got it yeah it's
it's that's life you gotta just bear
with it right like yeah yeah it's neat I
would say in that respect but yeah but
you know when the game has as many bugs
like this one does like even play on ps4
last night I couldn't lock on to an
enemy which meant I couldn't actually
fight him properly because this game has
a very sort of demanding combat system
where the angle you attack with your
blade is very important so because I
couldn't lock on I was simply just
moving the camera rather than the
orientation of my sword when things like
that happen you kind of regret not being
able to just jump back and save quickly
to try to you know undo the bug or at
least low to save and pray that it
doesn't happen mm-hmm so you know so I'm
just I'm just prepping just prepping
just putting soup is soup right in that
bowl and all and this is where the game
starts to get a little so it's it's
meant to be as we're describing very
punishing where like things are like you
know real and like risks are real and
you know yadda yadda but it but it makes
conveniences for itself when it's
convenient for itself for example like
you can die in a couple hits from a
weapon but if I stab someone who's
asleep 20 times they get to wake up
stretch their arms and call for help
and run away yeah so it's kind of
inconsistent in like how demanding and
how strict it can be anyway let's let's
let's just engage ourselves in the
moment and listen so that's one thing is
that we were making fun of the movement
in this game is pretty like it's not
just the neck it's like your lower chest
that caves like a Anatomy was different
back so basically your dad is saying
look I need charcoal to forge this sword
I need you to go to get some crap from
this guy who's a jerk and get me some
beer because I'm thirsty right and make
sure it's cold make sure it's cold I had
to go back yep yep my pocket my Papa
took a look at the beer and he threw in
my face he's just getting back down to
the
give me a cold one sob but dead also the
accents are kind of a keeper just
listing off things that bug us oh well
yeah so be it the the accents there's a
lot of American there are three
characters there are three characters in
this game who will have American accents
and it's 1403 in yeah we're exactly
[Music]
shows how American we are that yeah it
just like like so it's like there's a
bit of like you're got some German stuff
got some right right that's some Turkish
stuff sure okay so let's get right to it
let's get let's knock some of these
things out huh all right let's yeah
let's do the so you you want to go screw
with the guy first if if you'll if
you'll indulge me here okay so go or
actually okay go to the house where
you're supposed to meet your friends and
you have to do the poo throwing thing I
think you don't go to the tavern
yesterday yeah yeah yeah yeah you got to
hear this I had to he had to abduct the
King he had to the Empire is falling
asunder in his hands the German count
selected Rupesh of the Palatinate is
king because your Wenceslas would not go
to their deeds even German can't keep an
eye on old Fritz in the background here
[ __ ] a lot of swearing in this game yeah
the Austrians and nowadays not even the
devil himself can keep up with all the
Pope's which is the right foot Pope the
one in Rome it's true though winces is
the king of bohemian bohemian Nobles are
on his side
to hell with Surat SiC is once the sauce
commander-in-chief he stayed loyal to
the king and if he heard you talking
like this
he would have you whipped like a dog
yup set to sell Luxembourg to help your
king South Bohemia is with Sigismund and
forget about Putin what Germans like you
kissed sigismund's feet to keep their
heads like butts like the Niners which
is going too far
Wenceslas is our rice of [ __ ] Spokane
what can you do I might have an idea
don't deserves to be taught a lesson
doesn't he Fritz Deutsch was talking
such [ __ ] it made me think of that huge
pile of manure came the one on YouTube
we did not put up early yet we should
have that hopefully by the end of the
week catering for the start of next week
count me let's skip some this oh but
Fritz is so good okay that's Ford you
decide that you're going to annoy
Deutsch
by throwing horse manure at his house
yeah you know you can actually not do it
yes I was playing last night starting
over I decided to not do it look you
ain't cool so we're totally gonna do it
yeah we're gonna we're gonna pack the
manure like a snowball can you do me a
favor though my words exact
[Laughter]
can we try to circumvent their demand
you will get there okay I think you know
what I wanted
oh yeah so the another thing about this
game so that again the auto-saves are so
few and far between like any oh it's
like major quest miles yeah like I would
you can lose a half-hour progress like I
would love to punch someone right now
but for the sake of the stream we want
to get through this stuff so this is
really great so this is with Doris y
wife I believe right and she totally
can't hear you from this distance Oh
where's your hair but maybe you noticed
after all these years yeah so there's
like draw distance will be really okay
so there's a go try to screw with the
poop before you distract her so this is
where I have happens a lot is you'll see
the bottom right the use key I yeah you
can't so yeah a game supposed to be
super flexible you can't just cause
trouble okay fair enough
hey lady why are you sitting so close to
the [ __ ] of all the spots you're sewing
this is nice
here's a nice piece that I just want to
know if you're saying yeah I just went
by the tavern and your husband was in
there talking nonsense
I thought someone should take him home
before he gets himself in trouble
looks like the male character from
Andromeda I don't know if you with like
that weird Larry distance yeah a lot of
similarities
gamer's is yelling at us to find a
shovel and keep it we can do this here
we go yeah they were calling that dude
before Deutsche bringing out with these
poxy Choi sure you think that guy will
have some reaction to Dodge
yeah all right so here now we get
introduced to the combat system this
game and it's it's interesting it's
different Peter it's very different
so punches were slower
yeah so you lock on with a couple jabs
or do you yeah it's so it's directional
with the mouse oh yeah I got a kick oh
I've tried the king up in these
scenarios does it literally doesn't do
anything yeah which is the K but let's
get a quick jab awesome
nobody respects you yeah bow down whose
grips for sig is note all right so now
the cops are coming the catch pole is
are you familiar like his earth I've
never heard of that before
I'm sure it's legit but it's a catch
Pole yeah I love other runner yeah they
took the longest route ever like
multiple times guys I don't think you
should be following frits he's probably
not a good leader
I'm just saying even though they're not
have you tried tackling your friends you
can do that with the F button and they
just disappeared
hit F they'll disappear trying but
something you do it's like kind of
blurred out or maybe maybe not maybe not
in this scene hello right in
[Music]
I really want to punch someone yeah yeah
I was like in a later town I'm walking
around everyone's like oh how are you
doing good this woman like I don't know
where she goes Mondays we all good
morning how are you how are you want to
shake hands I don't have poop on my
hands that's working just take so long
yo you are the talk of the town everyone
wants to see you all pool hands they say
well there's a lot of like just every
line every opening is like gah be with
you you know I mean that was the deal
back then sure all right so I'll just
chat to these guys chat to these guys
get them to help you beat dudes boy move
oh this is gonna happen again you're
gonna run into each other see this is
what happened there last time they get
so close do it my friends now are we
Fritz hot what we're both were two
people
it's me Fritz a spoon yeah look where
you're going look where you're going
okay okay sorry I distracted by those
eyes Buster didn't stand a chance
[Music]
Kahn balls good points it's not as if
anyone really likes the noise anybody
nice job at the deutsches all right so
you probably gotta talk to them all
right so what you could also do is so
yeah you're trying to get money out of
this guy who borrowed tools or took
tools from your dad yeah yeah so you can
like you know use some speech on them I
think you can like sneak up behind him
and choke them out oh yeah yeah you can
do that you can get a lockpick and break
into his trunk right lock the lockpick
lockpick just different on a controller
on a mouse is it more easy on a control
okay maybe you have to engage moving
wood from one basket to the other what
do you say anything yeah okay my father
sent me to get the coin you owe him for
the apps number and nails
or else I would do the bottom one yeah
he'll come here himself and hammer those
nails into your hairy ass yeah
[Laughter]
of you great so now those are here I
would say you can expect a visit from
father that's fine and then go get your
friends okay if that's the way you want
it I'll tell father you won't pay and
you can tell him what you told me
all right so now forget your friends eat
them up and then I want you to if you
can quickly do the the charcoal and the
beer thing so that we can hopefully
trigger that cutscene which I mentioned
earlier okay pretty good how did things
end up at the deutsches okay
[Music]
also if you notice casually but like
it's really hard to tell training it's a
light drizzle no one got me errors at
all money to my father
but he won't pay I'll have to shake out
of him yeah for me you helped us so
we'll help you let's get to it then
really sound like him
alright let's do it guys I like you just
go right into it yeah I'm still need to
show you
it's my hairy ass and just start
swinging no it doesn't engage no just
hey
[Music]
oh yeah Oh
all right so definitely just keep eating
that really yep yeah seriously
I don't talk to him no okay knock him
out he needs to be incapacitated for the
cutscene where you go get oh I don't
think so you have a mean jump by the way
oh come here okay okay no God take all
this stuff okay take all this stuff oh I
can where it's closed you can they're
not that they're not really beneficial
okay okay so now just go you know soju
charcoal and that idea bit of charcoal
sell his clothes to afford that and then
flirt with your girlfriend get the beer
jump on those words oh yeah two horses
you see that at least like two pieces of
charcoal
[Laughter]
I don't sound yeah all right let's give
them this close to sell whatever you you
can use this connections close no I
think yes I've been just gonna buy now I
get so you get so you can do this all
from one screen if you got to buy and
then basket and then cash out so all you
need ten I already in this exchange
sabes and then go to basket o basket oh
you already did add ten I'm sorry
well you're gonna buy twenty your no I
think I took I took off my shirt by
accident is a screen this green shirts
mine I want that back okay okay we're
good okay sorry
let's close beer
no it's in here
yeah back yeah but whatever engine sir
I'm not familiar with my times yeah it
doesn't really matter it doesn't know
hey Bianca Bianca
Sandra am I sure enough you do baby so
in this this is the one I bring up to
Jake is that like they keep saying this
evening like in that you'll see it's
every other line is like you're gonna
bring me the money this evening I'll be
here this evening
oh they're foreshadow okay well then
I'll see you this evening okay well
let's hang out this evening boy I cannot
wait for the evening a picture as usual
I bring me a call my god center of
course everybody this game looks like a
mixture of Bam Margera and alex navarro
and the shark from Jaws nailed it that's
really funny what you've already taken
my dignity awesome kinda close back all
right so we're good right well that's
pretty awesome
such longtime gamers really wants us to
get arrested but no because when you get
a risky well do we have to do all this
all over again die automatically when
you get arrested because the town is
invaded and there's a huge fire and
you're trapped inside of your cell and
die there's there's no serving your time
and you could kill a chicken and die
yeah get arrested all caps I hope this
one buck for me Q's we're like so Teresa
comes and she wants nails and he give
her the nails and then the dad and
during the cutscene is like I gave I've
already given her the nails the dad's
like he's got a dope at though yeah and
apparently his past is that of a hero
and he doesn't want you to follow in his
footsteps
right oh wait I miss [ __ ] well what do
we up to now oh yeah I don't I don't
think I have to do the sword fighting
lesson
[Music]
sup dudes up dudes
chillin yes and challenges house have
you also noticed every single person he
talks to in town he tries to use as an
opportunity what are you looking at you
should go talk to your mom outside of
the house cuz last night I was talking
to her she would no longer face me when
talking she looked like a deaf woman who
did father sent me father looking at
forging a sword for cirrhotic and the
Chamberlain has to cross guard in grip
father had them engraved in sassa right
here the Chamberlain gave them to us for
you
we looked them over beautiful
I've never seen anything so thanks I
know just make sure you didn't botch it
ever watch anything shall I start things
happening this evening
you need a trapper keeper for all those
events right eighties purple trap let me
note that in my evening you might even
say there are other words for evening
tonight when you get hurt in this game
you basically go talk to mom and she
fixes you up save your game you do that
that's so much better
okay mom well my mom you gotta stay in
like to the side of her I would I screw
it up my boy I don't up here this looks
pretty great I think you're hungry
can I get mad at me now that's some
breakfast on the table help yourself
some cheese and apples yeah we're done
with you thanks
can you can you whistle whistle okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah solid Stern parenting hail to the
chief oh yes yes all right
but we gotta watch this slow ass walk
all the way to the
[Music]
this one this is my music really kicks
into this walk got so loud she let him
know what's up this boy's a puppies work
Henry you're you're a weird kid are you
ready
so can we get started
yeah which slowpoke
we can't okay all right all right
what's party the best teacher in the
land
who's never held a sword before what is
that position let's rock get rocking
baby
okay I think I got the movement down all
right put your weight into your attack
I said hidden around nowhere try
slashing from different sides
unpredictability is the key oh my god so
on playstation 4 I was doing this last
night yeah he wasn't moving his sword so
I was literally just whacking him in the
head with solder for stabbing airs for
breathing ok turn for throwing horses of
a jump whistles for whistling this
evening is a planning
oh yeah change strikes that's right hey
I think I need every either Henry needs
a breather
alright that's it yeah okay alright did
I give him the Ale already oh god if I
didn't give him the Ale it's too warm I
I bet I guarantee it
I don't know if I guarantee it I just
bet I know if I can make that guarantee
Peter I don't know if you can make this
hey get off I have its I gotta get more
beer yep I'm have to go get more beer
I'm Doug dad well if it does anything
gives us another time to jump horse
Shaun White ain't got nothing on have
you did you always have that ale queue
like did you have to fail every time
sorry did you get yelled at for being
warm every time I wonder if that's
something you can't avoid no no you're
quick enough he's cool
and the first time I talk to her see oh
you wanna you want to know some cool
trick yeah there's a whole bunch of like
plants and herbs over there you can pick
up and you can flip that and get some
money out of you trade it so that's how
you make a buck
alright here's your damn beer you
alcoholic did you say no matically I'll
be back soon did I not get I didn't get
I'm not paying attention I thought that
was it I talk to her again I didn't get
the Ale did I trying to whistle in your
face you deserve it Rob I'm sorry
everyone watching that's alright I just
really want to jump horse
everyone it's me Henry watch me Bianca
[Music]
yeah we know you need Savior snaps to
say if we know it's a very not gonna
give you the beer I didn't see a prompt
for the beer do we seriously break this
game come on let's talk trade I get
seeing a buyer from I'm not seeing ale
I'm assuming that's a beer
holy [ __ ] but I feel like it's an ale
quest items I'm do we break this I for
sure don't have you tried whistling at
her yeah seriously we flipped through
this game like or this portion of the
game like 10 times we know what we're
doing does not sure there is beer just
buy beer see what it's al I know I'm
just saying I don't know maybe you maybe
you need to go to the basement again
if Bianca will cooperate I don't mean
this evening dude I don't think it's
gonna work I think we have to go back
Wow go back to I don't know just some
save should we just load a future save
yeah Alice did you just talk to Fritz
before you talked to pop about his beer
why okay he says something says I the
beer will work okay I said L not beer
you're not my son stabs you the stories
making oh that's what I'm asking we have
to finish that sword today Wow you want
me to look a fool you know the sad panda
we just bought beard it doesn't work
this is bulldog it's stupid
Wow Wow
Wow I mean should I just get arrested
talk to Fritz I guess or try that I
really I really don't want it okay if
Fritz doesn't work just kill for it
just punch them to death I don't think
you can Oh
skulls too thick yeah pretty much kind
of seems pretty
punch a chicken while I'm over here just
like real life
feathered hey baby
dang it dude well where's fritz
it's fruit there's no telling man frets
could be anywhere - I [ __ ] maybe try
Bianca one more time and if at that
point just get arrested because his game
is broken that's super disappointing
okay Wow
for those of us who were just cake
sausage McMuffins doesn't burn the town
for those who are just joining us part
of this quest is that you need to bring
beer to your dad that's cold
you gotta get at their timely and timely
fashion well we tried to do that but our
dad didn't take the beer we went to go
do something else came back discovered
he had not taken the beer the beer we
had was too warm so we went to go get
more beer and lo and behold the game
decides that we've had enough
I do have charcoal and therefore we
can't complete the opening quest in the
game because it is I have charcoal I'm
everything we've got charcoal we've got
so here's the thing
Oh coz the marker is gone I don't even
have I don't even have that quest yeah
broken broken broken alright let's punch
some people yeah no fine who deserves it
is it your death you can't there's some
people you can't punch what punch that
horse though oh you definitely can't
punch the horse hey hey buddy key art
[Laughter]
he's trying to telling you that other
horse aren't you - stick up for me [ __ ]
you
where somebody how this man is punching
horses no he's gonna kill them now which
target oh no wait no beep I'll take
longer I think I think you can actually
run away but also this is [ __ ]
because at some point this early on you
basically don't stand a chance of
anything he's still going to arrest you
isn't giving don't give a hell if you
agree with imprisonment you were
agreeing to your death you were signing
your death warrant [ __ ] frankly for
a game that doesn't allow you to say
whenever you well I've raised my speech
level great good for you you're about to
die watch this central gamers we have
the charcoal yeah I showed you sorry to
disappoint you I actually had more than
enough charcoal we stole all his crap
and Bart that bought the charcoal and
now we're gonna die
at least it's broken it could get really
good but we have no way of knowing
OOP men let's watch the death scene okay
it's pretty good dancing
[Music]
over here try whistling she might hear
you
[Music]
[Music]
Henry never whistles
and scene I love that band
The Grateful Dead yeah all right let's
get back into it do you need please have
some of those quests or something it's
not gonna be like that I had the demo
again don't I oh this is after you yeah
she's going to check on her her husband
I really didn't want that to happen this
is a realistic game and reality doesn't
care about what you want
say what you will about the save system
whoo bitchin tunes let's do it your
liver is that of a dainty flower dizzy
death this is after patch this is not
pretty bad they've said that they know
there are problems with this game and
it'll take at least on the PlayStation
version a few weeks to go out we're
playing PC much faster oh this game
could be really good in time but it's
not it's not there also at $60 also it's
60 bucks it should really be called
early access I mean we literally just
broke the first quest right yeah that
was the first like the first quest yeah
the first quest can be broken just by
doing what seems logical damn this all
takes so damn long so and your precious
field trip where are you going you're
just dude um if I know this part so well
these slowpokes I'd love to pull I want
to punch that yeah can you jump over I
bet you could clear that couch easy yeah
so tiring
let's eat baby eat Essen Appa what is
the Apple in Germany again fo
meet the lads a pinch Koosh Koosh oh ok
probably you know I probably do is
expedite all this yeah let's get some oh
no way I probably need some to sell you
can sell the clothes off your back
literally which given the given the
extent of the screen you might as well
just do that alright where are you
what's up boys are back oh nice light
jog
dude Central Time gamers man we got this
yellow dust it's ok alright so now I go
talk to [ __ ] ish time gamer says you
should talk to frits you scratch my back
I'll scratch yours
I love Fritz so that's the same dialogue
yep we can't talk to Fritz and
accomplish magic you talk to fritz I
don't want to my father sent me to get
the coin you up
look No whoa damn guys my mom oh well
it's about to happen he's probably gonna
kick your ass
thank you you're anything like me yes
when I get my buddies involved guys what
Oh
what'd he just teleport oh yeah
yah dass ich teleport hey friends help
just talk oh I can't tell you great if
you let him kick your ass you won't die
okay
he's basically just like yeah I'm an old
man you're a boy took his diary to stab
we've sorted out kunai show you show me
you up let's get to it
okuni
there's chickens it's my wiener it's so
tired in this game so yeah right Christ
can't you see combat whoa I am I am seen
red hang back enjoy the show
all right definitely murder no no I
think I think they're gonna hit it with
the next one I think I think they know
what they're doing who grabbed body okay
so yeah get the beer get the he'll talk
to Papa
I guess Oh take care of Kurdish eat some
cheese all right a cheese did you what's
that I call on the bottom right Pig
you're kind of a pig I think is what
it's saying you look like a pig
yeah oh that's a pig see that's Pig
vision oh yeah
Oh Pig vision yeah all right let's buy
some of this you got no food okay I love
it your dad is like so go buy me some
[ __ ] also soldier dad
also this trader just sells charcoal
that's it also you have 40 charcoal no
he does the trader he has just charcoal
he is the charcoal dealer
everyone's gotta make a living okay the
best charcoal in town well I got lentil
soup I'll have some of that I should be
good all right so this is his right
central gamers Fritz having a lockpick
is so unimportant but I love that you
keep bringing it up so please keep
bringing it dude knows his game all
right
Oh
shred I didn't go to basket or what
kisum what the opening quest to this
game is broken I don't know
I like damn it damn it damn it damn it
oh my god red I'm seeing rad dude did
you don't eat I thought I didn't eat my
lentil Oh is your eye damaged you might
actually talk to mother
all right okay let's just go do that
then because I can't stand this
Peter you think that like upon what you
played this part twice I've played it
before I played this four times I call
me a pop Henry you are a weird weird boy
so stand to the side of her no no not in
front of her place thank you
yes I want to see if she looks at you
hopefully she does Henry come here so I
can feel your face she just
breathes out aid there we go hey Rob did
you know if you just get the lockpick
from fritz you can rob the dudes house
and get your dad's tools back oh my gosh
that ball is out oh you know what time
it is did it did it in there did it
everyone watch me great wound riveting
conversation hey tying your shoes
picking sage you idiot duh oh my god why
do you walk so slow
let's go do this again amigos
where are we going what are you doing
cute that was cute
it felt so real oh my god what is that
pig icon mean I wish it would tell me so
someone just the name scrolled by in
shadow hey Rob if you just get the
lockpick from fritz you can rob the
deuce house and get your dad's tools
back
I don't need tools some guy just said
that we're [ __ ] around and that's why
nothing's happening the game literally
broke and we had to start the game over
so I hate to admit it but are you ready
yet am I kind of afraid to speed through
these cutscenes it's gonna break it yes
movement can you move left and right use
those things we call feet walking by and
seeing this training
I wonder what happened to bees leave the
area I don't want to try I kind of want
you to try that's what happened it's
just put your leg down
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's chain I know
could you tell I've done this before
No
I love that guy okay so what ale have
you already talked to the do to the
castle castle and Yale so let's do it
Ross Scott let's do the cross guard
first yeah I know a shortcut
[Laughter]
I just I just think we should get that
lockpick for it sighs is that it is that
that's the that's the bug that's the
hill you're gonna die on wait wait wait
turn your right it was just something
floating and subdued how your hand small
today go be with you I'm with you how
are you that stupid don't speed
perfect I did that quest so well next
all right Bianca get the a already
Papa's thirsty
but first names Henry I'm gonna be the
best horse troponins Sochi 2016 me pops
hates me but I want to be a horse jump
hook just get the pic Rob for [ __ ]
sake you're not looking so well honey
there's luck all over your face here we
go let's just get right to it you leave
the Deutsch out of this
I bring me a cool Oh your warmest ale
please
boiling hot it's a wait what he's
talking about your hands Henry you're
becoming a man your arm is too long in
the game what the hell what the hell
it's not cold enough erm what is this
like 20 seconds cold oh yeah hell yeah
daddy loves me
that's what I can't trust with you three
checks are out no come on no I want to
get out I would like to get off this
wild ride
you're trespassing nails for Theresa as
well take all this stuff whistle at her
damn it
please I hope so I've given her the
nails maybe we'll see each other there
again for me the dad was like I already
gave the nails because like just oh yeah
yeah
old man look at that young watch - so
what the hell is up with this evening
man is jam-packed this Friday night
freakin dance he's got a date oh yeah
yeah fine job I would expect nothing
less from such a renowned swordsman
actually I like the scene when Henry's
days ago oh my blade oh you see that way
to equals reliability you like to try
shut up shut the hell up
okay here we go here we go Henry Henry
your metal your training good go t like
yours and damage learning his trade will
serve him better in life sir who knows
what the future holds for each of this
this evening just need to polish are you
going to the wedding tonight after the
dance very fine there'll be a parade if
I'd have had it's like back in the
Kabbalists things would have worked out
differently right
oh the honor is mine sir adzick thank
you for the poor Henry a long peculiar
history never mind
here we go steel Zeitung
this game gets crazy
what should we go back okay
Oh Oh No
the odds are truly stacked against us
dad you're seen my wig we're here for
the dance
Oh No they should run with arrows like
that take this your name is how it was
Hank
he goes listen how Timmy yes cuz that is
that his nickname no you do what I say
right now I need to die
go Henry
in in actuality didn't want to tell
Henry was like Henry your kind of [ __ ] I
think so you just run beta you just run
hard and go into that chest that trunk
earlier in the game like we did there's
nothing else in there yeah no I did I
just did right but your dad's like oh
yeah take the stuff
oh it's underneath the board may not
have been able to beat that stick in the
ground but I can definitely beat these
no I'm feeling good now I can do this
the power of Christ compels me this part
is really effed up
yeah dad
[Music]
oh yeah dad it took him that long damn
it are you slow
sorry pal he too he was doing like 850
360 horse jumps we had to stop here have
a stamina back I'll see you this evening
dance dance also this is like yeah the
mom really gets it every yeah what do
you see what happens to who needs the
nails Theresa
have you seen my wig you look like a
nice wig I like your hair boy whatever
happened to fritz ooh what if fritz
comes back to save the day
[Music]
that would be amazing oh nice shooting
we can make it just kidding
[Music]
look at that run look at this run
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
dum-dum boy when are you gonna find what
I learned
look what I learned stop right I learned
kitchens earlier oh you should
absolutely run so during these moments
if you do not like run as quickly as
possible and do your thing as quickly as
possible you will basically be killed
before you can reach your next objective
off-road X Games X Games X Games Bohemia
okay so should I try and save her if you
want to die I I said screw her Jake was
able to save her I'll try I'll try it's
it's impossible he did it who did it
Jake I'm saying no he didn't yes he did
I think rob is lying to me yeah I think
this is a joke don't be
yeah so about that how did Jake do that
Jake didn't do it he said he did I think
you miss remembered so basically you
it's it's damn near impossible to stop
Theresa from being raped and the game is
telling you prevent this save Theresa by
whistling at the gun all right you
should have used the snitch there's one
thing Henry can do is even whistle in
jump do that jump is so addicting like a
party thinks if I can get enough speed I
can fly so someone's saying if you
distract them they'll run to safety
but in my experience distracting them
also leads to you dying so you know
let's give it a shot give it a shot
controls
okay all right she just went through the
I don't get on this horse semen through
the building yeah
later losers okay all right okay we
saved her I'm cool with that
I'm glad you can do that myth busted
I stand corrected for skiers oh hell
yeah so here comes the fun part you got
through this in one try Jake did this
about 20 times and nearly threw his
hands up I'm just better at Horsham Oh
me and IG needs better than GameSpot
yeah really
ah damn crap crap turds double turds
well enough of that let's do this do
this hey guys hey friends
oh you missed missed Oh Oh see you
shouldn't have tripped on that rock Rob
because now you're not gonna make it
well I haven't used my nitrous yet there
it is that's the nitrous I think they
still behind me do you have any courage
so you're about to run out of stamina
not challenge run for it
are they gonna kill that guy I bet not
they don't care about him he's not how
how damn again ign's better than
GameSpot [ __ ] damn it's gonna call out
hey guy do you think we should run for
it I'm just curious what your thoughts
are hey idiot get off the road
move it or lose it whoa oh shoot yeah
you're gonna stand
no I'm good you might make it come on
hey our x-man and YouTube chat what game
are you talking about that we got paid
to rate the game good because I would
like that money yep come on dude I'm
gonna make it
I'm also bathing oh is that what happens
I bleed out or is that what yeah what's
happened to Jake come on horse no they
just kept hey you made it
you done did it right anyway horse farts
oh now you can dodge arrows Maggie
Maggie Hogan ease
[Music]
[Music]
wait but what's that guy's name is Rob
Lord or whatever it is it's something
good our robbed our road our anyways he
sounded British just there but I'm
pretty sure his accent changes oh he's
got it like a Brooklyn accent yeah it's
American I don't about Brooklyn all
right close it
no we're safe now that's my job it's got
hair on my leg my name's Andre of an
arrow am I like my friends call me how
[Laughter]
someone give him a drink and bring hot
wine and bandages get him a Bud Light
and some french fries this is the 15th
century
I said coke got a Coke Zero and where
are you from what who's your daddy and
what does he do they burned it to the
ground slaughtered everyone who who
burned it to the ground
they attacked without warning and the
word which tatars precious what do you
have that this evening tartar you mean
talk to sauce
I'm gonna pull that hair out it's an
arrows son don't touch the wound you've
got poop all done
you were lucky lad the arrow missed the
bone yeah real lucky war is a good
teacher can you stand just like mr.
Phillips my cool that's me right thank
you like I'm not interesting and that's
work no no let's keep going manage I'm
crying dude I'm just kidding I'll I'll
give you a hand
boil em mash them stick a [ __ ] to thank
you that's American actually what
exactly happened did you see my name's
Steve I'm from Mississippi how are you
it's good to meet you today
14:03 but a lot of people took refuge in
the castle I wasn't quick enough as I
fled they shouted from the battlements
that I should come and warn you I tried
whistling but didn't recognize they
could be those humans of sigismund's it
said they came to humans now they're the
core of his army sacking Guttenberg must
have given him a taste for stolen silver
scholars is a small castle sir
if Sigismund attacks they can't hold I
swear he started off with a British
accent rhobar our small garrison would
be no help even if we could risk sending
them
you think we're next to mine doing what
to skip this what's your name boy no
we'll listen I'm Henry I know him did he
make it inside the castle no I'm sorry
it's in God's eyes so did you nod or
shake your head I do it was so subtle
like some toe
look more like a rotation anyway thank
you for risking your neck to warn us and
what a neck it is Robards take care of
Henry
let me smooch and Robart get all the
people inside the gates we have to
prepare for this year's I was gonna say
Bobby did all the necessary arrangements
evening will be as you command a special
evening give me a piggyback ride that's
not want to see that dogs dead see
someone says that dog just chilling them
where's two dogs one was totally dead
okay so I want you to put you okay so
what I want you to do continued like
talk to robo robert and get to the point
where it's like you go to bed because
the other problem I have with this game
is that it really doesn't give you the
choice of freedom that it lets you think
that you have and this is best
illustrated in you've gotten what scene
coming up I'm sorry
meanwhile you get punished real hard for
doing anything else in five minutes the
game doesn't play by its own rules I
heard damn I can't understand why he'd
waste his talents but is anybody
listening to me I'm following him yeah
but he's a generous man and a good one
so remember this we're going to come
back to this room you learned a kitchen
you learned kitchens milady
you're fortunate a good lady Stephanie
of Homburg has graced us with their
presence
welcome lad
Bojana here we'll take care of you no
doubt you're tired and hungry indeed how
could he not be poor soul after
everything these what happened to my leg
band I look fine is it good yeah I'm
good to go now shirt in the span of 20
seconds oh yeah what the hell eat you
Phil he was he escorted me out I wasn't
able to walk are you Phil no do you so
robot after all he's been through from
the dead lets him sleep in a lodge in
the courtyard
young Henry here is overwhelmed by your
generosity yes yes thank you milady
may God reward you for your kindness eat
up now you're in capable hands so I'll
leave you to it good night good night
good night man
yeah as tip inator in the twitch chat
points out did Henry forget that his
parents just died and everything he'd
loved and new to the ground not Henry
not good old hound like howl was
introduced just like that's it no here's
the thing
if anyone else calls him howl go away
his dad called his dad in disguise let's
good call okay so you're like in weird
slow motion apparently cuz I'm Harry
you're famished
all right just steal it's for keeping my
pockets warm all right let's eat the
cabbage you have cabbage cabbage is like
the most hearty thing but you don't have
any cabbage so oh dude do you know
cabbage stats in this game yeah man
nice you don't know cabbage stats nope
yeah they call me the cabbage stats kid
oh wow
dirt dirt hmm I'm taking all your food
scram I help you look at my cabbage ooh
jackpot okay
oh I'm gonna drop something in here I
can't drop
Oh
greetings from those I'm getting out of
here
you guys are weird all right get some
sleep and if you don't mind wake up in
the middle of the night you basically go
to those beds behind you I think look
like damn good horses to jump there's
time for the plenty of time for that
later go to sleep sleep oh man okay so
oh okay I want you to wake up in the
middle of the night okay so just
whatever yeah now what I want you to do
is to try to kill someone who's asleep
which you think would be a very easy
task and luckily when you sleep you save
so now we are free to do what everyone
mind doing flips and whistling in horses
it was badass he said look at me and I
couldn't help it yes yes forgive the
intrusion thank you boy no you did yeah
actually what is that dish she has there
bones
great okay so yeah oh don't don't tell
the story of the raid I just can't talk
it's a real good story takes like 40
minutes yeah but it's a damn good story
I'm sorry Mikey but I can't talk about
it everyone close to me died there okay
all right we've got some emotional
baggage you learned women in the Middle
Ages and those who managed to take cover
still all right she's acting like she
knows the story but I refuse to tell her
[Laughter]
you learned women in the Middle Ages
again
oh and uh it's gonna show you fries just
slinging turns Pig site come on come on
kill them all now people in the chat are
talking about man I've heard this game
it's mostly pretty long I believe it I
believe but I'm not sure it's of course
this is apparently just the prologue of
course the game also broke during the
prologue you asked some people it's
because we didn't get a lock pick from a
bracelet
and yeah tough pill to swallow wake up
you don't want to miss this it's going
hey this is very important watch this
yeah right let me sleep my parents are
dead yeah I warned you all okay it's the
middle of the night Henry I'm sorry you
need to watch this so I need you to go
back into that kitchen area and I need
you to try to kill someone grab this
Horch weirdly because I bet you could
stab someone ten times in the neck and
they won't die
wait what I just duplicate a torch I do
that whoa
I totally just duplicated a torch can
you duplicate a horse but of course a
horse is a torture torture horse oh this
door nailed it
torches in the rain my favorite all
right it's me no you guys had bad dreams
- okay I take a sword and start stabbing
okay this realistic game will not let me
kill someone in their sleep you can't do
it you can't just just go just go
[Music]
that's better than when I was playing
last time last time I stab someone like
there's dozen times in a row
no problems here she's so strong
how was she so strong not gonna watch
you're gonna build in like two hits oh
yeah you're gonna kill me and so few
hits oh yeah all right defend this game
please somebody defend this game because
$60
he's killing you with a wooden stick you
stabbed in the neck well we all know how
Henry handles wooden sticks Oh am i dead
yeah all right let's get to the actual
game yep
oh wait that wasn't it nope so now they
ask you to go stand up you know at the
top of the wall and watch this stuff and
it's like hey you can pass time just you
just touch the touchpad and I was like
nah I think what's gonna wait it out
it's at like 20 minutes doing something
else
my character literally stood there
nothing happens at night not a damn
thing
it's the game trying to tutorial eyes
the act of pressing a button to pass
time and if you just choose just to
actually see it through nothing happens
I guess that's real but it's not like if
my point is this intro was very long and
it doesn't need to take this loan to
accomplish what it wants to accomplish
yeah it's also not very realistic so
these guys are pretty realistic talking
to each other yeah I stare at friends
all the time just like that
[Laughter]
it's behold pandit ism yeah we're not
trying to break the game the game broke
by itself earlier we had to cancel the
first mission and go back we've been
playing this game for a day and we're
very tired of its inconsistencies let's
say and it's wait are there two of him
what do you mean or is that a different
there were two care does it look like
okay yeah this game should actually be
early access I don't know yeah it
doesn't make sense
why would Sigismund advance on Tom buggy
night if I if I bought this for six
dollars I would return the framerate
holds upgrade ah you know this goes for
a Rick we have here which is said to be
pretty great again ten seven eti so
drugs I have this one high setting
somewhere to get a solid and not even
solid as you can see by as I see the
glowing cotton balls around white hairs
and you were right Sigismund has a hell
of a lot of soldiers including all
Master Edison Ares means there'll be
like well anyway we'll find out when
they get here
I really like this dialogue here namely
that it's like all these people just
been left stranded from the town and
they have the longest conversation in
the ring how's dad sounds like a jerk
but I'm just curious
wounded women and children behind them
[Music]
believe it or not this tempest is a
godsend for me and my men as my old
granddad used to say better a sore
throat than a sling I'd say your
grandfather was a wise man
your messenger told us what happened
messenger he calls himself how how on
earth did you manage to get away thank
God for this tempest when it begun
dude's a [ __ ] liar do you know those
damn rain I just I just need some cold
ale and a hilt for my sword and maybe
some charcoal I don't know do you have
any whistling horse jumpers up there for
those asking I have played ps4 version
it actually like in terms of like
framerate and stuff like that is pretty
okay it's not bad it's slightly degraded
from these high settings on PC it's
probably close to medium I didn't enjoy
it any less than playing it on PC and in
fact maybe has made a little bit easier
the controls were weird though you know
talking about bugs there was a bug where
I literally could not lock on to the
people I was fighting which meant that I
couldn't swing my sword in the direction
I needed to
couldn't win a battle like why is just a
silly thing not a bug or anything but
just a decision the control menu screen
shows your controller you know image of
it and then shows you what these buttons
do they've got the the the the
controller like flipped in such a way
that the the L buttons are on the right
hand side of the screen so you're led to
believe unless you really study it that
oh no that's that's not r1 that's L one
on my right-hand side again not about
like sort of just evidence of like maybe
this thing needs a little more time by
the way Henry my condolences
thank you this guy's this guy's American
what do you think about how reminds me I
thought well we were all expecting the
worst and the truth is that's he for
said when Sigismund comes here and come
he will of that I'm sure
I just hope by the way Henry here he
said that look let me tell you how to
slack off kid
you just stand here and stare your buddy
x travels like no hey Henry yeah weren't
you supposed to stand guard no that's it
I did it you did yeah I just did to
guard all right pretty sure mmm let's
check my quest go oh no this is when now
they introduce fast travel right here
here we go one hour two hours that's
enough
it's called time travel Rob any well
you're just standing there in place for
three hours and people are walking like
is this guy how how like creeping you
out at all oh just watch Hey gamespot
red and dead in the twitch chat thanks
for asking our review should be up
either the end of this week or early
next week it's kind of a long game we
didn't get it until last Thursday
and doing our best we gotta get the game
finished I'm gonna get the review text
in turn that into a script cut a video
review make sure it's all up to our
standards and then share it with you
guys I'm not I'm not even trying to
break it
what's going on guys that legs all heels
look at him run yeah he's good to go man
just a flesh wound it's just a few hours
are you guys looking at Oh
see how the self-appointed king indeed
indeed the slow you learned medieval
women again oh no something else look at
all these guys I guess that settles that
yeah so basically they I can remember
what happens been this far so yeah
that's really I can't remember why that
the army like leaves you basically like
convince them that you don't want any
trouble you don't have any beer go away
drink from the pot what Oh
fade to black
all right put this torch away
is this a yes it's a weapon I wish I
could do something about the blood what
do I need to do now oh that's right so
mmm I want to go back to my hometown and
bury my bury my my mom and pop sorrow
bard I have a robot the [ __ ] Joyce
was talking [ __ ] you can't do that I
have to bury my parents my parents died
there and I won't leave them to be
rubbish by dogs
I have to bury them good God boy do you
want to throw you down those who can
never get theirs back
alright well that's about it so actually
I want to see if I can I can pay the
gatekeeper because it looked like there
was a way you could do it are you the
keymaster
I am the keymaster hell yeah into a 360
did I or whistle yeah you've kind of
like raised the bar at this point we
can't go back to the standard hops I
thought one of those was definitely your
horse it is this is it horse no oh steel
you're right mate I have it yeah this is
it this is my baby are you getting on
inside how did you let the horse control
is that very tough on console they're
actually not too bad on PC it's just
your perspective oh he's a camel yeah I
know when I look down on horses in real
life all right
let's see if I can use my Henry with you
okay we gotta get out of this place and
I need a featherbed with a kind oh it
kind of looks like Jimmy Fallon no I'm
thinking of SNL guys Jewish gave orders
not to open Oh Bill Hader yeah looks
like you later yeah yeah I love it
that's fine thank you
I need to bury my parents oh okay so my
parents are dead my parents are dead
I think I can pay him stocks he's your
old gamespot jokes
I'll make how about one gold I'm giving
you everything bill okay bill to make it
so I've got some point recognize you
then okay so I was able to a class I'd
be happy if they happen you know all
right I'll have a look around for
something but first I need to go bury my
parents okay let's see if I can find
this armored quest log Henry's log how
uh get a horse so I don't know where to
so it should be a that should be marked
with a on your little oh you're
absolutely right good call all right
thank you it's near my bed
[Music]
yeah I was in the next door no kindness
no what do you think this is realistic
yes it's on my map again I like this
your PO is just like you look like a no
yeah you do huh old chess piece is it in
my room
oh I bet it's in here but you don't have
a lockpick you dingus yeah you're right
he he know what he was right
hot dogs getcha we should have we should
have gone that lock thing chatters
that's my room look more things let's
see this evening you should run down the
river and grab the lockpick from fritz
this evening then once you do that this
evening you shall go and escape by
picking the evening lock Thank You dr.
fleen much appreciated aye dude oh this
is where I got stuck down there I was
Tanya I think this is it red and dead in
the twitch chat who is brian blessed
there brian blessed see someone I should
know lock back do you know him look in
the trunk you can't long-distance I'm
taking this for sure jackpot better
long-distance about those oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah celebrate man don't just
let it out freakin party man yeah so
make sure you walk with your hands in
front of you as much as possible
okay give me out I'm hearing you in and
out
should I try murder when these dudes and
get take their armor use this save your
snaps first [ __ ] dude hell yeah alright
gulp gulp gulp saved okay who is brian
blessed
people keep telling me about him I don't
know who he is are you gonna get him in
the noggin Oh
also we've learned that enemies don't
die as easily as they should I don't
know so here's the thing I'm pretty I'm
pretty new to bow and arrow oh no you
just come save this dude walking around
the corner alright oh here we go
so gaming dude I don't know how to
regaining central and central time
gamers are both talking about locked
packs and I feel like I'm lost in a
paradox here who is the real center of
gaming between the two of you because I
can't figure it out we turned down I
just want to know how to use this damn
bow it's not like you hold down right
Mouse you'd think
ranged weapon to right where you press
the two button so you need to use the
two button activate it slash and then
just follow your heart I think
Oh
you can also choke him out apparently
can sneak up behind him and choke him
out
okay nothing nothing
that's heart under sword
how do i choke them out you that crash
oh hell yeah baby
note it out what you see over there oh
[ __ ] yes yes yes
he's gonna kill you by twisting that
thing in your shoulder this that's all
it takes to murder you
[ __ ] I really thought I had him
there I know no he didn't think so no I
thought you did but then I remembered
what game we were playing Oh
any chance remaining need to crouch oh
yes crouch all right let's try that
again
chruch what are you doing with that
thing there do I hold
oh my god you can't defend this
are you gonna clearly I want to do with
the hard way this game sick
dude who cares we're out of stamina we
stab this guy in the face ten times he's
not dead I can't pay you vintage where
could you you're a criminal who's
committed a crime against an innocent
person I'm going to put you in a jam the
castle where I currently live and you
are standing
oh how freakin later dudes
I'm just gonna leave I'm supposed to
leave so I'm just gonna leave but can
you stab this bear over
Oh 360 misty flip I think he did
something but I like it alright let's
try to make some progress enough
playtime yeah
the combat music still playing yeah of
course it is never forget
remember remember Henry ooh
Mario sorry who's Henry I'm how Henry's
not here anymore just have fun - tis
omit doesn't make sense dude if I'm
stabbing a guy in the face with a sword
it doesn't matter how my stats are it's
just not the way realism
like if my nephew eight-year-old stabbed
me with a knife I would die despite
having more experience poison it's just
the way it goes I'm going to bury my
parents leave me alone now people just
they don't want to accept with this game
as problems it's very interesting I
commend you for seeing through them
because I can't yeah it's hard it's hard
to do
so what do we think is that what are the
highlights I mean well I I don't what I
want to see is really I think you said
it to me yesterday is like okay why is
this game worth 60 bucks like what what
is it that commands that price we're
like this is on par with other games
that we believe should be you know full
play full price ready for market
oh I'm struck I'm really struggling to
grasp like anything beyond the like the
map the map seems like I want to know
this world I want to see what else is in
it cuz I feel like there's got to be
some cool stuff but I'm also looking to
leave that it's not gonna be I'm not
gonna like stumbling to side-quests in
the woods I don't think right like I'm
gonna have to go to towns and find
people I think I don't know I guess
we'll find out but yeah like it still
doesn't feel like this game is opened up
as as water promised I would expect
right so that's what that's why I'm like
kind of pushing through but because it
has it has amazing potential I really do
think it's got potential mm-hmm me too
but I also think that a lot of the
arguments used to defend this game are
they they don't work agree there's no
work also I would really like to fire my
arrow
it was in your pocket just someone know
and chat how I can lockpick Fritz with
the lockpick so I'll say it to God there
you go the Doolittle I'm hitting both
I'm holding look at the controls again
zhenya does anyone know how we fire I
have a feeling I have to be like in
combat or something like that
that's [ __ ] you can swing your story
that's how to combat you can - yeah
you're right I have to be equipped get
to put your nose in there maybe that's
it you have to okay there you go alright
just like real life
oh hell you kill that cab oh hell yeah
now we're talking but give them some
fair warning first
alright now it's fair game on you've
committed a crime and I'm going to
arrest well there's no crosshair so
that's kind of cool
dave-o in the push okay why did you are
you going to die now because you feel to
get a horse oh no I will I'm doing my
quest I'm just like I did that was like
you're supposed to go without with
direct in that direction to go activate
this class I understand you kind of just
skipped all yeah
Henry has seen
I'm not Henry anymore that's how there
is no Henry
which bloody mess
[Music]
you're not my father
[Music]
no okay I'm sorry
pundit ism the problem with going far
enough to trigger the cutscene is that
we were nowhere near town so it kind of
flies in the face of and I and I bring
that point up again because the game is
so punishing when you don't sick Oh
it'll stick into the stone but not
broken oh hell yeah let's loot dude you
want that boat too you can behind dude
you finish that hi my name is howl all
right we'll come back and loot those
bodies later
for now yeah you got a berry mom and dad
yeah yeah we got it apparently that's
when the game begins did you know the
game hasn't started yet
Oh
[Music]
okay so it's this way
[Music]
whoa hey Adam oh you didn't say anything
about apples before okay where's my
sword are you serious
did I drop it somehow what did I
accidentally drop it at some point I
don't know man wait but I think you're
screwed oh it's there it's a quest item
that's why
Jesus Christ now see that was your
brother the long-lost brother who go
that way let me alone bullets everyone's
carrying fruit all right you're
different
wish I had that horse
nice don't like horseradish dear he can
keep that
pretzels it's probably really soggy
so you might get bandits coming up to
attack you Oh tip least no what did
these poor souls ever do to them man how
many lockpicks are you missing we need
that I wish I had more lockpicks
I wish they like gave opportunities to
get lockpicks in this game or like if
you had a friend yeah kind of character
that you like
it stopped raining
check the shooter my name is how oh nice
- probably shouldn't whistle oh fast
travel
oh [ __ ] can I pass travel
you go to a skeleton you're their mama
thanks for the bread YUM
okay we're getting closer
that's right I'll use the back door
horsie
why would they do this just me is that
you haha he was born to die thanks for
your baseball bat like that I like to
clang it made when it connected who are
you looking at oh now I get it
alright mom dad oh I don't think we're
in Kansas anymore as good as I did used
to buy acai
yeah I remember we used to jump over
horses you remember a number right here
okay so
the how is that you I'll be some cool
air why did you do it's me Father what
why did you leave me
forgive me is he gonna rob him forgive
me
next time I won't run I'll never run
away guess
I'll [ __ ] the one who did this to you I
remember his face I'll find him there is
no Henry
but first I have to find these softeners
let's take care of you what about mom
the man's world
I remember you told me you wanted to lie
beside mother
yeah
under the linden tree
any starting to do that goes for you
do you think George's house let's check
could be burned down where it's the only
one that didn't burn down
all right thanks mom dad you gotta find
a spade dude okay thank you that Kenya
good luck good luck I got a feeling it's
this way
nope
spade spades spades babe speed is a
shovel yeah
more or less I heard dog
I was a stake new perk all right that's
new let's check this out get perky get
perked okay I'm Henry where's uh where
do I put this perk cuz they're already
used it's already used me it's just oh
it is yeah I was confused that's it as
far as I can tell it said I thought I
wasn't applying I had to have something
available to use
I think it's boosting the more you run
dobkiss by spirit find the dog find the
space so it's getting pretty hot in this
room how much longer you want to scream
before we could proud to call it I mean
I don't know maybe we should I'm kind of
I'm kind of spent already and who knows
how long it's gonna take - shovel we go
for two hours and 15 minutes really that
bang all right well I got to eat - yeah
talk about what your oh the dog is it
the dog is the Spade that's right
I thank you for joining us and sticking
with us and telling us about all the
lockpicks we missed along the way I
think I think I'm gonna try to keep
playing this game I think yeah I think I
mean apparently it gets good after this
yeah I'm willing to give a shot me too
I'm willing give it a shot have some
laughs along the way yeah maybe we'll
stream again maybe we should yeah thank
you for sticking with us and watching
everyone hope you have a great day come
back to game spot every day pretty much
for a stream at 11 a.m. Pacific time I'm
Peter Browns Rob handler hi thanks again
you
you
you